well the problem is you're not just
scheming for him you know Floyd is not a
bag of rocks guys a great player they
have two of the best inside players in
the league and I have a great blitz key
so it's easier said than done
put two guys on Mac they blitz enough
where you can't get help Jon Gruden
preparing for the inevitable on Sunday
in London when he finally gets to face
the guy he traded away for more lottery
tickets he had a lottery ticket that was
an all-time winner the grand jackpot and
he traded him away for more lottery
tickets and now he has to face Khalil
Mack look I the Raiders
surprised me in Indianapolis I thought
they were gonna get destroyed by the
Colts so I'm a little hesitant about
this one but the Bears look pretty damn
good even with chase Daniel would
quarterback that defense is so dominant
I don't think it's gonna matter against
Oakland Mike I'm very disappointed in
you and your analysis of this game I
thought you would bring up the
all-important travel schedule because we
have two different approaches you love
to talk about stuff like this
the Raiders went from Indianapolis to
London the Bears waited until yesterday
to go to London I actually think that
helps the Bears even though you want to
talk about body clock the Raiders have
now been on the road forever
they left from Oakland to go to
Indianapolis and they went straight to
London once you get to that fifth sixth
day on the road you want to go home it's
weird it's not normal so I think that
also helps the Bears they were gonna win
anyway but come on Mike throw the people
a bone let's talk about some travel
scheduling I know you love that stuff I
didn't even mention it at all I haven't
mentioned it I in weeks and here's the
thing about London now that you pulled
me down that rabbit hole but there's no
clear answer to what's right and look I
mean what's the Raiders alternative
they're gonna hang around Indianapolis
all due respect I love Indianapolis if
you're gonna hang around there for five
days and then go to London you may as
well just go to London and get
acclimated and I don't think it's gonna
matter we're not gonna be able to tell
the difference because the Bears are
gonna kill them whether they play in
London
Chicago Oakland or Tokyo big agree I
think the Raiders are in a big big world
of hurt here with especially with Khalil
Mack that extra motivation I mean Khalil
Mack
is already incredible and then add a
little extra motivation
Rokon smith said he's going to play
chase daniel is gonna be fine
I think the Bears defense is gonna
dominate probably pick up a score
themselves and the Bears are gonna win
by ten plus what a difference a week
makes in the AFC North the Ravens are
now two and two the Browns are two and
two and here the Steelers at one and
three hosting Baltimore it still is one
of the great rivalries in football big
cat and even without Ben Roethlisberger
Mason Rudolph they have that offense
with the controlled passing game they
got Jalen Samuels playing the Wildcat
quarterback and contributing in the
running game and receiving game and look
I know it was just the Bengals Monday
night but I saw a renewed fire and
spirit in the Steelers that we hadn't
seen all season and they're definitely
gonna be bringing it on Sunday against
the team that they hate yeah and the
Ravens are one of those teams where Mike
we have you know what they've done in
the past in our mind in in the present
you see the Ravens out there you see the
purple jerseys you think their defense
is flying around their defense has given
up now over a thousand yards in two
weeks in a two-week stretch and when you
look at their schedule I still feel like
we are living off that big 12 score it
looked like Oklahoma versus Kansas week
one when the Ravens played the Dolphins
were living off of that because then
they played the Cardinals tight week to
lost so the Chiefs that score wasn't as
close as the game was and then gotten
barest by the Browns I think the Ravens
have some big big big time issues on the
defensive side of the ball and I think
the Steelers like you said are going to
be jacked up for this game it's gonna be
close but I think the Steelers will
we'll be back in this picture and would
it be classic Mike the year where the
hype for Lamar Jackson is is rolling and
he's been great the year where the hype
for the Browns is rolling and they've
been good the Steelers lose Big Ben and
then somehow find a way to still win the
AFC North yeah pull the inside straight
I remember they had a couple of horrible
games 30 years ago they got blown up by
the Browns blown up by the Bengals
everyone gave up on them and they made
it to the to the round of 8 that year
with bubby Brister I think at
quarterback
one last thing about the Ravens I think
they came out of those first two games
thinking this is going to be a special
season and I think they emptied the tank
at Kansas City and pulled all those
tricks and went forward on fourth down
and went 4-2 they did everything they
could to try to win that game because a
special season truly happens if you beat
the Chiefs in Kansas City and I think it
popped the balloon for them and now
they're just trying to figure out where
they are and I think they're walking
into a buzzsaw in Pittsburgh I agree
with you I think the Steelers gonna win
that game all right
Tampa Bay at New Orleans Jameis Winston
trying to eat a W back in the building
where he created that gift for the ages
two years ago when they were trying to
beat the Saints there they failed that
day will they fail this time yes they
will because this is one of those
situations where the NFL so week to week
and your fear up one week you're down
the next everyone loves the Box because
of what they did in LA people are saying
Bruce Arians has fixed Jameis Winston
but now he has to go to the dome now he
has to play against a defensive line
like the Saints I think this is going to
be an revert you know step back for
Jameis Winston he's gonna revert to old
Jameis turn the ball over and the Saints
Teddy Bridgewater is not lighting the
world on fire he's not throwing the ball
downfield he's kind of a I don't want to
say he's a game manager but he's
somewhat of a game manager but it works
for the Saints because they clearly have
a way about you know what they're doing
they have a system they're going to win
the game now with their home crowd
advantage with their defense with their
running game and I think the Saints will
win this game somewhere in the four to
seven range if that gives you a clue on
what you want to take I agree with you
on that and you know my theory on the
Saints has been I don't know if I
mentioned this last week but I feel like
the Drew Brees injury was the hard reset
for the Saints the reboot of the
computer that made them forget about the
NFC Championship game forget about the
Minneapolis miracle and just rally the
troops and do what they can to try to
win football games without Drew Brees
and here they are they won in Seattle
they beat the Cowboys Sean Payton
shortlist coach of the year for what
he's accomplished without Brees and I
think
they keep it rolling Mike mark it down
741 in the morning that's the earliest
you've ever done made a good point when
I'm on the show there you go Wow good I
like that point I really do I like that
point I think it changes the you know
the dynamic of the locker room and they
have to say hey now you know everyone's
against us no one expects us to win it's
you know people are saying it's a lost
season and they can rally around Teddy
Bridgewater 741 earliest you've ever
made a good point on this show well next
week I'll go for 724 no G the over-under
next year all right bills and Titans get
together the Music City miracle rematch
19 years later and my take on the Titan
is very simple it's been proven out when
you expect them to lose they win when
you expect them to win they lose so I
expect the bills to win this weekend
regardless of whether it's Josh Allen or
Matt Berkeley at quarterback big cat and
not only that I agree again with that
you're on a roll that's two for two on
takes even though you just mentioned the
Music City miracle like they haven't
played in the last 19 years that was a
right now about you still yeah it's a
weird thing by you but I'm not the guy
talking about make up calls from 2015 on
Clay Matthews that was a different team
that men said I think people are gonna
see the bills here and they're saying
okay they play the Patriots tough last
week there's gonna be a letdown effect I
actually think it's going to be the
reverse effect because the bills played
the Patriots so close that they went
away from that game saying hey we have
something here this is a this is a team
that can build on it this is a team that
if you know Josh Hollan can take care of
the ball a little bit more and guess
what if Josh Islands in the fourth
quarter there if you've watched any Josh
Allen he just makes plays down the
stretch that's when he does the Josh
Allen thing where he runs around and he
makes game-winning plays so they're
going into this game saying we can win
this game we have something here and
Mike Circle this game right now because
this game could decide that six seed in
the AFC wild card these are going to be
two teams that will I would imagine are
going to be around that nine and seven
zone and this could mean a lot when we
look back in late December trying to
figure out who's in the in the playoffs
and who's not I mean I appreciate the
analysis it was very cogent it was
lucid and and it was persuasive but it's
very simple for me
Titans are favored so they lose if they
were the underdogs they would win
that's the mic variable Titan experience
hi I think you stole that from me first
of all and second of all I'll give you
another one on top of that bills a
revenge game for Music City miracle well
you know what how about 22:16 final
score Bill's win that would be the
ultimate revenge because that was the
final score the Music City miracle all
right
Packers Cowboys the big late game on
Sunday 10 early games to late games
nobody cares about charges Broncos
everybody cares about Packers Cowboys
both teams lost last week they're trying
to get it right i-if Davante Adams does
not play I've got no faith in the
Packers offense and I don't know how
much faith I have in the Cowboys offense
after what happened in New Orleans but I
got more faith in them right now than
Green Bay I have a lot of faith in the
Cowboys offense in this game because
what happened to the Cowboys in New
Orleans is that the Saints have a
premier defensive line and they're able
to basically say go ahead and try to
beat us when you can't set up the run
where you can't have a Zico Elliott run
the ball and set up that play-action
that you know Kellen Moore and dak
Prescott want to do the Packers are a
different scenario altogether they have
regressed every single week when it
comes to run defense Mike they got
absolutely gashed by the Eagles last
week they did it happened as well
against the the reason why I Joe Flacco
actually put together a decent game and
they had a close game with the Broncos
the same thing the run defense wasn't
there the the Cowboys are gonna be able
to do whatever they want on offense
because if the Cowboys can run the ball
everything opens up for them and
everything looks easy you know exactly
what I'm talking about when dak Prescott
runs play-action and there's not a
defender anywhere close to him and he
can roll out and has all day to throw it
downfield that's what's gonna happen so
I I think Aaron Rodgers will be able to
keep it close because he's Aaron Rodgers
but the Cowboys are going to be able to
do what they want on offense and I'm
gonna say there's gonna be a lot of
points yeah and look Aaron Rodgers
looked great last Thursday night
but if Davante Adams is out of the mix I
don't know who's gonna draw attention
away from marques Valdes scantling at
Jimmy Graham Geronimo
Allisyn guys who that if all of a sudden
they're there blanketed with extra help
the extra help that usually goes to
Adams I don't know that they're gonna
get it done that that's why I believe in
the Cowboys in this one but you know I
had a great game both teams start at 3
and out they were feeling good about
themselves one of them's gonna be 3 and
2 barring a tie and and then you just
have to continue to dig out but I like
the home team I like the Cowboys in that
one all right and the Colts and the
Chiefs getting together Sunday Night
Football here's that here's the problem
Patrick mahomes is on stop and we're
gonna talk about that later in the
program but the guy is one of the best
quarterbacks I've ever seen no he's the
best quarterback I've ever seen and I
think it's fair to say and only a 2nd
season as a starter he's arguably the
best ever at what he can do with a
football what he can do with his legs
the whole package the release point the
the release speed everything about it
Patrick mahomes is incredible and the
Colts are gonna find out firsthand and
apparently they've been picking the
brain of Justin Houston one of the new
teammates to get tips on mahomes you can
tell them all you want it's not gonna
matter because you're still gonna have
to go stop him and no one can well the
Colts already found out first hand and
it was in that playoff game that you
just showed but you're right Mike
Patrick Holmes is simply incredible the
craziest part about Patrick mahomes
and being incredible and as good as he
is he's actually statistically and and
maybe not like the Ross that's maybe not
yards touchdowns whenever even though he
had no touchdowns last week he
statistically not been as good as he was
last year and he's still incredible so
it's like people are saying you know
he's taking maybe a tiny smidgen of a
step back because there's always that
correction the market correction the NFL
and he's still dominant and he's still
incredible so I'm with you here I think
the Chiefs I think this is one of those
show out games for the Chiefs where
they'll run it up a little bit and you
know remind everyone that it's not just
the Patriots it's also the Chiefs in the
AFC yeah I agree with you completely and
really it is the Patriots and the Chiefs
great offense great defense and they're
destined to meet in the regular season
December 8th and it feels like they're
destined to meet again in the postseason
Vikings and Giants meet again at MetLife
Stadium there was a stretch where they
played every single year and this is an
opportunity now for the Vikings to try
to get right after
debacle last week at Soldier Field and
ordinarily I'd say this is a game the
Vikings should win and they tend to win
the games they're supposed to win they
lose the games they're not supposed to
win and Kirk Cousins plays poorly in the
games they're not supposed to win but
after everything that's happened this
week with with Adam Thielen calling him
out Kirk Cousins apologizing publicly to
Phelan Stefon Diggs clearly wanting out
and no sense that anybody is really in
position to clunk heads together and get
everyone on the same page I think this
could end up being a disaster for the
Vikings yeah I agree with you it could
be a disaster for the Vikings remember
this is also a revenge game though for
the Vikings for the NFC Championship
game in 2001 so it'll be interesting to
see if I agree with you Mike that those
are in there in disarray right now
here's the only thing that I'll say in
favor of the Vikings in this game
they're gonna be able to run the
football and if the Vikings can run the
football everything else works because
Kirk Cousins if he has to throw it 30
times
you're gonna lose you're gonna have a
bad time so I think it's going to be a
competitive game on the other side
Daniel Jones getting golden tape back
right now at a perfect time when you
know that's a perfect complement to what
he is doing and what he's doing is a you
know young quarterback of the league I
think there's gonna be a tight game I'd
go with the Vikings but it's going to be
close and I think it's would be an
exciting game one of those games it pops
up and you're like oh that's a really
good game that's fun to watch if it's
close the Vikings will lose just like I
said two weeks ago with the Raiders if
it's close the Vikings will lose if the
Vikings win it's gonna be about 10
points or more and and Kevin Stefanski
the offensive coordinator is he gonna
feel any heat to maybe open up the
passing game a little bit to placate
Diggs and feeling this could get
complicated this could be the Vikings
thinking too much Kirk Cousins thinking
too much but I agree with you if they
just run the ball run the ball run the
ball they should be fine oh by the way
sacrum Barclay still might play in this
when they have not ruled him out even
though he's only two weeks removed from
a high ankle sprain Jags Panthers real
quickly Minshew versus Kyle and who do
you like in that one who I went against
Kyle or sorry Gardner Minshew last week
and I feel like you know such an idiot
when I watched that last Drive and saw
that moxie and saw him put the ball in
his hand so
I'll stay with the minshew mania I'll go
with the Jaguars
I'm gonna just ride it till I get off at
this point I until it falls off from
riding the Jaguars I'm riding minshew
mania
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports